who has a new children's book called
carla and the christmas cornbread it is
out now
the holiday season is fast approaching
and we want to make it a little bit
easier i can't think of anyone i'd
rather do this with we're going to open
up the turkey hotline
all right well we got an overwhelming
amount of questions on our hotline and
one of the most popular
was
what to do if you don't want to cook a
full turkey
what does one do carla one of the things
that i love is that you can get a breast
that's usually skinless and boneless
flatten it out
stuff it
roll it tie it up so you do a roulade
you know it's funny that you mention a
roulade carla because i actually have a
thanksgiving roulade that's what it's
called
come on um in uh the new cookbook that
palarvel does and i just made called
rebel homemaker and one thing i do like
bringing to a classic thanksgiving
dinner though
is one of these
they're also good for other times too
just kidding
so i'm gonna just
like butter
do you see that
let me pick it up let me see how
beautiful that is and it's juicy you all
can't see the juice
look at that look
oh my god
oh my
that's right but that is how moist it is
and you're right about the juices carla
it's making me salivate with juices too
because when i see food i drool
yes okay there's another question that i
think people always ask
or not to brine if you're gonna brine do
you do a wet brine or do you do a dry
bride now i have to admit i'm not very
familiar with the dry brine i have done
a wet brine what how do you execute a
dry bride leave out the water that makes
sense
that makes sense but do you oh right i
see what you're saying sorry no but by
the way i got yes like step one no water
yeah and then step two uh salt is a
compliment but you can also add flavors
to your salt so we have salt here i'm
going to put in a spice grinder and then
some of those peppercorns
okay the whole thing oh
here okay that's all right and then um
no no it'll be fine and then we're going
to add some lemon zest you can do you
could do it with the
micro microplane thank you so what we're
going to do is that's of a whole lemon
half a lemon do the whole lemon i kind
of didn't do the whole thing but you
have pepperoni on the day on the day
we're going to make a lemon pepper salt
oh i know
okay
no i did not put that on right oh we're
going to push at the same time ready one
two three
[Applause]
does it all come together yeah
that's good oh my gosh
and this pepper okay but look
so
take it easy on the smell oh whoa that
really yeah so we're going to sprinkle
this on sprinkle over yep sprinkle this
put a little bit in the cavity i do like
getting up in the cavity
personal
yep so you're going to put this on the
night before you're going to place this
in your fridge and honestly when it
comes out you will you can rinse it off
you can pat it dry it's going to be
great all of the fibers that the salt
goes into the meat it's going to be
delicious because the thing is that most
people think basin is a thing you know
what happens when you baste one you're
just on top two you're lowering the
temperature of the oven that's why it
takes your turkey so low so i've only
ever done a wet brine i did a two day
star anise peppercorn bay leaf brine
then compound butter
sage thyme butter mixture under the skin
then drape the whole thing in bacon
and then put it in the oven and you know
what i gotta say shut your face yes i
did
i did and it came out
it came out really well
wet brine drag
there's no right there's no wrong but
now we know how to do it carla hall i
love you carla and the christmas
cornbread is on sale now this is what
we're going to be reading in our family
for the holidays i'm so excited and
before
[Music]
you